the first thing I want to talk about is
he talks about debate and the state of
debate right now so if we can go to that
it'll be 11 40 to 12 38 and then Rollo
I'll come to you I want to get your
reaction to what he says
I think that all of the people who
disagree with me are very very welcome
to disagree with me because they have
had a unique life path and a different
point of view and I respect that
absolutely I would never shout for any
of the people who just screwed anything
I say to be silenced or canceled because
I don't think that that helps the world
I think that discourse is always going
to be the way that we lead ourselves to
the truth and if anybody has anything
contrary to say about any of my points
of view I welcome it I like to hear it
and as long as it's in a respectful and
adult manner I often platform it on my
platforms as much as possible so I can
sit and discuss and I can learn things
because if I have a point of view and
someone challenges it in a very adult
correct logical way very often I have
changed my point of view this was the
moment we can stop you there this was
the moment for me where I said this is a
different guy than what I've seen in
these clips this I haven't seen this guy
before because just that moment of
saying I can learn something that's
something I say that's something I think
you and I had that conversation before
you sat down lie with me you're like hey
maybe I'll walk out of this room I'll
think about this differently or think
that is the nature of someone who
welcomes actual conversation so when you
hear that I hear that and I say that guy
just gained fans by speaking out like
that I think people inclined to disagree
with him on some content are gonna rally
behind him because of things he said
like that what was your take on that
moment right um I mentioned this
yesterday in my show
um first off uh this is uh The Logical
extension of getting banned okay there's
he's not the first one to get banned off
of off of social media or get like
cancel like simultaneously you got to
remember what happened to him he lost
his YouTube he lost his Twitter he lost
his uh tick he wasn't even on Tick Tock
and they banned him off of tick tock
they killed his Instagram they basically
disappeared him digitally simultaneously
all within the same week much like they
did Alex Jones much like they did uh
Rush V much like they did Milo
yiannopoulos from back in the past so
this is a pattern this is something that
you can expect if you're putting this
kind of material out and you're
outrageous enough that people are going
to start to take notice uh Andrew also
had the effect of the the the plan his
his uh his organization let's just say
is he had a hundred at least a hundred
thousand I think I I don't know what the
exact numbers are but he had at least a
hundred thousand guys in Hustlers
University who were rebroadcasting his
own material and they are getting banned
too so that's how serious a threat that
big Tech takes him right now and so now
we're going to transition into the Free
Speech aspect of all of this uh should
he be able to say what he wants to say
well what he's saying is clearly
dangerous enough for every one of those
platforms to simultaneously disconnect
him same thing for his payment
processors I'm not going to say who they
are but his his two payment processors
also dropped him on the same week so
this is a coordinated effort so it's not
just like hey guys uh well we're going
to ban him how about you it's it's a
coordinated effort so that's something
that I think we need to remember for the
future for when guys who are like Tate
or it doesn't even necessarily have to
be in the manosphere this is the
possibility and plan ahead understand
that this is complete chess not Checkers
right so when I see this and he's 100
right I agree like um uh you know
theoretically philosophically I
understand that I've said this before I
have an oblique I think I said this to
you on your show I have an obligation to
objective truth and the only way you get
to that is Through The Crucible of open
debate you cannot test the strength of
an idea unless you can actually talk
about that idea well the problem is we
don't don't have any problem when we're
talking about like Republicans versus
Democrats or the left versus the right
or conservative the you know versus
liberal or progressivism of that kind we
don't have any problem talking about
that we can still have those
conversations and not get canceled or
not get as canceled the moment you bring
up intersectional Dynamics the moment
you say there's a difference between men
and women physical neurological
psychological when you point out those
differences and when you start talking
about the unflattering truths about
men's nature and women's nature that
gets you simultaneously banned after
what six or eight months if you get to a
point where they take notice of you
that's when you lose your platform
that's when you lose your voice and it's
as Rush V used to say it's when they
take away your bread it's when they kill
your Revenue it's when they make you uh
unable to do anything that you've you've
been doing up to this point now he's
been on uh Rumble and he's been on some
uh he's trying to make a move over to
getter and some other like alternative
platforms which by the way if you saw
his most recent video on Rumble he
generated I want to say was like 140 or
145
000 live views on Rumble it is the it
was the top live view show on Rumble
ever in fact the CEO I think of of
Rumble was like commenting about this on
an article not too long ago but that's
how popular his message is that's what's
getting out right now and that's what
like this generation of the lost boys
want to hear and they want to they want
to see you know they want to get behind
them they want to be like Tate's Army
kind of thing and the problem with this
is that's what the the big Tech who
canceled him were afraid of it's not
necessarily him as a as a person it's
the idea it's it's the the uh the
broadcasting or the dissemination of
those ideas and that's what really I
think that they're threatened by so when
you look at like political discourse
when you look at like we can talk about
the recession we can talk about uh Biden
we can talk about anything you want to X
except for intersectional Dynamics
except for anything that puts men and
women in an unflattering light because
we're shining a light on on basic
biological evolutionary
differences between men and women that's
too dangerous for them to have on their
platforms and with that I think goes the
topic of gender identity because a lot
of the people in the political sphere
that are being banned being suspended
being threatened right now are talking
about this gender identity Theory and
and if in order to have that
conversation you have to be able to say
this is a biological man this is a
biological women and in order to further
assess that conversation you have to be
willing to acknowledge that men and
women are in fact different there are
differences so everyone's saying that is
also you know that's why I say it's not
women are not exempts from the Banning
women are out there right now
conservative women are out there having
these conversations and they're facing
the same nonsense on Twitter you'll
constantly see somebody oh I was just
suspended again for saying just a basic
biological fact so what I always say is
that you know the powers that be and by
that it usually means you know Network
television cable news often oftentimes
in large part funded by big Pharma by
the way which benefits from all of these
conversations going in one way
um and you know the powers that be in
Silicon Valley oftentimes unite and they
decide okay we will allow some degree of
dissent but on these safe topics that
we're okay with and will allow The
Descent to go this far once it crosses
that line we will suspend once you touch
a topic that they're not okay with it's
like an off-limits topic they're not
okay with that suddenly you're suspended
so you know this is a moment I think you
talked about you know the Tate Army I
think there is a lot of that a lot of
rallying behind him but I also think
there's going to be a rallying behind
him from people who are like you know
what this isn't even about Tate this is
much bigger than Tate because who's it
going to be next maybe it's going to be
somebody they like a conservative talk
radio host maybe it's going to be
whoever whoever maybe it's going to be
somebody who speaks out against Planned
Parenthood you know you know the topics
we all know them that you can't touch
without worrying that you're going to
face a ban or a suspension of some kind
I think that's why Rumble is now growing
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]